extraordinary revelations in his first
TV interview since being fired the
former FBI's former director is telling
60 minutes why he launched
investigations into President Trump if
you remember Andrew McCabe was a career
official at the Justice Department who
oversaw the bureau's investigations into
Russia's election meddling and Hillary
Clinton's emails he took over as Acting
FBI director in May of 2017 after James
Comey was fired in his new book the
threat how the FBI protects America in
the age of terror and Trump McCabe
describes extraordinary measures Justice
Department officials took after commis
firing he says he was concerned about
the president's possible ties to Russia
now remember last march about one day
before McCabe was scheduled to retire he
was fired by then Attorney General Jeff
Sessions the Justice Department accused
McCabe of misleading investigators about
sharing information with the media now
he denies any wrongdoing but as a result
of his firing McCabe did not receive his
full benefits and is considering a
lawsuit well now in an interview with
Scott Pelley for Sunday 60 minutes
McCabe discussed a meeting with the
president in the Oval Office
just hours after Comey was fired I was
speaking to the man who had just run for
the presidency and it XI and won the
election for the presidency and who
might have done so with the aid of the
government of Russia
our most formidable adversary on the
world stage and that was something that
troubled me greatly how long was it
after that that you decided to start the
obstruction of justice and
counterintelligence investigations
involving the president I think the next
day I met with the team investigating
the Russia cases and I asked the team to
go back and conduct an assessment to
determine where are we with these
efforts and what steps do we need to
take going forward I was very concerned
that I was able to put the Russia case
on absolutely solid ground in an
indelible fashion that were I removed
quickly or reassigned or fired that the
case could not be
closed or vanish in the night without a
trace I wanted to make sure that our
case was on solid ground and if somebody
came in behind me and closed it and
tried to walk away from it they would
not be able to do that without creating
a record of why they'd made that
decision
you wanted a documentary record that's
right that those investigations had
begun because you feared that they would
be made to go away that's exactly right
the White House responded to the opening
of that investigation calling it
completely baseless investigation but
now we're hearing directly from McCabe
as he tells his own story with Scott
Pelley on 60 minutes Scott and good
morning good morning this is fascinating
to see what you've learned in this
interview he was a career FBI
professional this is the first time
however that he's confirmed he opened
that investigation why well it was about
eight days in May and 2017 right after
Jim Comey was fired and McCabe describes
a chaotic time especially at the Justice
Department when questions are being
asked whether Jim Comey was fired to
obstruct the Russia investigation and if
so is the president an agent of Russia
there were two investigations Nora one a
criminal investigation the other account
or intelligence investigation McCabe
told us that he had many reasons to open
both of those investigations and as we
just heard him say he wanted to get
those investigations open so that if he
got fired right away they wouldn't just
disappear what did he say about friction
in the White House after the firing of
coaming well he tells the story John of
the president repeatedly in meetings and
phone calls trying to convince him
McCabe that everyone at the FBI wanted
Comey fired and that everyone was very
happy about that and McCain talks about
the interview it talks in the interview
on 60 minutes about him telling the
president no sir that's not what
happened I'm encountering people in the
hallway who are in tears over the firing
of Jim Comey and he says it was at that
point
that he realized that if he hadn't
burned the bridge with the president he
could certainly smell it smoking it's
certainly a very candid conversation and
I've only read an excerpt from the book
but he is he's speaking very candidly
about his feelings for the President and
his impression of the president was
there anything in the interview that
surprised you about what he was saying
Gail the most illuminating and
surprising thing in the interview to me
were these eight days in May when all of
these things were happening behind the
scenes that the American people really
didn't know about there were meetings at
the Justice Department in which it was
discussed whether the vice president and
a majority of the cabinet could be
brought together to remove the President
of the United States under the 25th
amendment these were the eight days from
commis firing to the point that Robert
Muller was appointed special counsel and
the highest levels of American law
enforcement were trying to figure out
what to do with the president and I just
want to put a finer point on that
because there has been reporting but I
don't believe there has been a source
that went on the record to confirm that
that 25th amendment was discussed about
removing the president so McCabe is
saying that that was discussed
absolutely McCabe nor as you point out
is the very first person involved in
these meetings who has come out and
spoken there was a discussion underway
about removing the President of the
United States there they were counting
noses they were not not asking cabinet
members whether they would vote for or
against removing the president but they
were speculating this person would be
with us that person would not be and
they were counting noses in that effort
and this was not perceived to be a joke
this was not perceived to be a joke it
was also said at a previous time that
the Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein offered to wear a wire into
the White House to record potentially
criminal incriminated conversations with
the president a statement was released
after that that that was never serious
it was sarcastic etc McCabe and our
interview says no it came up more than
once and it was so serious that he took
it to the lawyers at the FBI to discuss
it mr. Rosen Stein seems to deny that in
a very carefully worded statement though
it's very interesting
McCabe's version and rod rosen sides
version of that
rod Rosenstein says that he never
authorized wearing a wire into the White
House but that's not what we're talking
about here we're talking about
discussing whether it was a possibility
did you have a hard time keeping your
face on straight while you're talking in
because he really says some jaw-dropping
things I did Gail silently say to myself
during the interview I can't believe I'm
hearing this it seems as though he was
trying to reinforce how surreal and
abnormal all of this was he'd never seen
anything like this he'd been in the FBI
his whole career he'd wanted to be there
since he was in law school heroes hid a
sterling career it became head of the
prestigious Washington field office the
head of counterterrorism and rose all
the way to the number two position at
the FBI and this was without a doubt the
most surreal moment he'd ever
experienced way to see it yeah ordinary
interview and reporting Scott thank you
and to everybody at 60 minutes great to
be with you on CBS this morning thank
you and McCabe reveals more of his
conversations with the president it's
got 16 minutes report on Sunday that's
at 7 6 central right here on CBS just a
fascinating interview and once again
reiterating that the 25th amendment you
know was something they were considering